so thank you everyone for coming I have
to apologize in advance because of my
Italian accent and I owe a slight fever
today so I'll try to hold on one more
hour thank you for coming again so today
I would like to share with you some
ideas of how you could build and deploy
your machine learning models in the
cloud and I'll also show you a real
world use case which is what we have
done at cloud Academy about the same
topic so quick introduction about me I'm
a computer scientist but I'm also web
developer and I have a son in music
engineering background I've been working
web development for about six seven
years and I was lucky enough to join
cloud Academy three and a half years ago
when we started building the platform
and basically what you do is teach our
students how to use cloud computing in a
vendor-neutral way so you can learn
about AWS Google cloud platform and any
other cloud and we're out there so we
use Python for like 90% of our code base
I'm also front-end developer so I still
do JavaScript a lot so I assume that
many many of you are data scientists or
at least already working at a science
field but for those of you who do not I
would like to introduce you Bob how
about I I think you can relate to Bob
because he's a very curious person
pretty smart he loves Python and data so
he always loved numbers and dealing
analyzing data and he knows how to build
machine learning models and especially
he likes to focus on user centered
machine learning which is what's coming
up in the recent new years which means
you do not use machine learning and data
knowledge is only for you know offline
and a posteriori analysis but you
actually use it to build smart
application in real time to make better
websites better applications and to give
a better experience to your filin users
why I am
highlighting this well because this
brings a lot more problems as you can
imagine as far as Cal ability which is
why the cloud comes in handy in this
case of course we've seen a lot of
tutorials yesterday and a lot of demos
today about how you can build and
machine learning model in even less than
thirty lines of code this is quite
powerful you can do it with tools and
frameworks like scikit-learn today I
will I will show only like scikit-learn
code so if you if you check this this
link here you can find like 3040 lines
of code comments included where you can
basically build test train and test a
machine learning model in Python super
quickly you can find all the links at
the presentation on SlideShare with the
link down here so you all know you can
do it pretty quickly as long as your
data set is meaningful it's not garbage
and as long as you know what they're
doing that's the assumption here but
there is a problem you do not just take
that code and throw it to production
there are a few problems to solve first
so what usually happens okay you take
Bob you give it some data and some time
he will come up with a lot of
interesting artifacts maybe data
visualization tools a beautiful
mathematical model of what the data
looks like and eventually a prototype a
prototype is by definition not
production ready right especially if you
use tools like scikit-learn you will
never end up with a production ready to
all that scales so what what happens how
do you deploy this prototype to
production well what happens you usually
need some help you ask to your web
developer to your develops team to spend
a lot of time on your prototype
eventually to even rewrite it in other
language and at the end of the day you
will go to production but it is my team
they might take like three times as much
the time you took to to design and make
your prototype
ready to use so why doesn't this happen
why there is this lack in the process
like why cannot you be the owner of your
own machine learning models into
production why do you need adverbs or a
web developer to integrate all your
stuff into the website or the mobile
application or whatever software
application you're building well of
course it's a skill gap because you're
not supposed to know about operations
cloud infrastructure or you know even
the best software software best
practices sometimes you know why you are
prototyping prototyping they are not
your main focus you want to focus on
statistical analyses and mining your
data and finding the best mathematical
model these are completely different
skills that will create what I hear
called
lack of ownership because you're never
the owner of your code into production
if too many steps too many alterations
too many operations come in-between so
again what what what are the challenges
with deploying your machine learning
models and as I mentioned your pipes are
not production already there are many
problems as far as elasticity and
availability so what you can see in this
chart maybe you've seen this chart many
times when you talk about cloud
computing what do you do traditionally
is you have this step oriented capacity
curve while you want to be elastic
okay your demand usually changes over
time goes up and goes down and what
organizations do is you know you have to
over provision or under provision it
means sometimes you spend too much and
sometimes your performance suck so it's
a tough choice and what you can do with
the cloud is to basically scale em be as
flexible as your demand but only not
only this Bob also wants to have a lot
of features and functionalities around
his machine learning models because
maybe you're building
another recommendation engine or
whatever and it will be used by you know
a web server by a browser by the mobile
application and you want to make it
available maybe we are restful interface
maybe you want to make it secure so you
want to have an authentication layer
maybe you want to cache the results
maybe you want to version your models
you want to a/b test your models these
are all functionalities that do not come
for free with your prototype because
that's just a model
so either you call these features
yourself or you find alternative
solutions you can also avoid the
features but you know that's not the
point this is even harder if you have
hundreds of models you know even if you
are a small data science team like we
are at cloud Academy you will end up
with a lot a lot of models that will
change over time that will be it be
tested with each other and you will end
up with eventually hundreds of them
and so these elasticity and features lag
will be a real problem there is one
alternative which is machine learning as
a service which I do not recommend to
you to be honest but only because you
guys know what you're doing and you want
to have control over your models but in
many other situations you may want to
use one of these tools and platforms to
basically remove the problem out of your
daily processes so that you can use
Amazon machine learning or Google
prediction API or Watson analytics to
you know you just throw your data at
them and they will find a way to give
you a machine learning model to give you
a functional microservices that you can
call and I mean this could be cheaper
this could be faster this could be more
intuitive if you do not really know what
you're doing but if you need more
control if you want to choose what model
and how to how your data will be you
know manipulated and you know just to
have more control this is not the best
solution
so what are and the alternative if you
want to do it yourself um well this is
some simple Python code that almost
suite of code actually that you know you
could you have your app web application
okay
naive solution you just build your
stupid web controller okay you load your
model before even starting and then you
will serve new predictions you know read
input transform it to make it compatible
with your model create a new prediction
and return it so this is like a five
lines of code naive implementation but
it comes with a lot of problems arm
first of all you need to restart the
server or the application order to
update your model or in order to yeah
basically the model is a local file so
every time you want to change it you
need to restart the application you are
probably using the same authentication
layer as your web app which is not the
best way to go because maybe you want to
have you want to be more flexible or you
want to make it available to many
different clients as I mentioned like a
mobile app or a browser or your web
server and what about like shared
processes and shared resources if your
model takes a second to return a
prediction your web app is stuck okay so
this is too naive too simple you don't
want to share all these resources with
your website itself okay you can say you
know problem I will throw more servers
at the problem um so you can have bigger
capacity now it's quite easy with the
cloud like AWS or Google um
but you still have most of the problems
that I just mentioned and you also have
many more machines to to manage to
maintain to patch and unless you
actually have the DevOps team you will
need those a lot of lot more operations
here and you still not elastic you might
end up overpronation
provisioning again okay no problem let's
go with auto scaling there are many
services out there on AWS or Google or
you're an average cloud platform that
allows you to basically scale and
achieve elasticity and high availability
meaning that you can be elastic maybe
not on a millisecond basis but say you
know hourly basis you can okay all the
machine machines are too busy right now
let's spawn a new one okay good you are
a bit more elastic here but again same
problems your web app will be stuck if
your models hang or anything you might
think about using containers but here
you if you have an even bigger lack of
ownership because as a data scientist
maybe you don't want to deal with all
these tools about operations about
infrastructure management which will
make the whole system even more
complicated and also what about all the
features that we mention authentication
layer versioning caching you're still
stuck with your simple web application
integration and so there is a new
deployment strategy that I am proposing
today and that many organizations and
startups and companies are using since a
couple of years and it's we call it a
server list it means you do not need to
manage servers it means the
infrastructure is managed of course you
can bring your own code and what you can
think of are basically functions so
instead of deploying and up instead of
deploying a container instead of
deploying a machine learning model you
deploy your lambda functions so some
people call this function as a service
instead of serverless this allows you
elasticity and not only that but you
also pay-as-you-go
meaning you only pay if your code is
executed if it's not if it if for a week
nobody calls your function you do not
pay and that's quite a good deal even
for your for your budget and not only
this but you also get a lot of features
for free
I think I'll list them later on
but so what's what
the point here a white serverless of
course there are servers didn't take the
key point is that it's not up to you to
manage them you don't have to worry
about them and if you have never if you
never deal with infrastructure every day
maybe you don't care but at some point
in the process you will be you'll be
asked you'll be asked to make your model
scale into an infrastructure will become
a problem so we believe that managed
services would be kind of the future of
the cloud which is where Amazon and
Google and Microsoft are going and so a
few benefits that you that you may
consider as I mentioned you'll be
elastic both as far as computing and as
far as pricing and available meaning no
downtime it means you are deploying a
new model you know you don't have to
deal those 10 15 seconds of downtime of
your web application which sometimes is
not removable from your pipeline it
comes with very very little operational
effort meaning as a data scientist or a
software engineer or you do not have to
deal with all the develops and cloud
operations also this kind of brings you
into the micro services approach that
allows you to isolate failure and
decentralize all your infrastructure so
instead of thinking of web apps or
controllers or or Python files that you
need to execute you can think of micro
services so you will have a restful
interface and it will be completely
isolated and they will be eventually
variant and you can have many different
stages like you can have a dev stage of
production stage your personal stage if
you want to do local testing and in a
way even if you're using scikit-learn or
other not production ready frameworks or
libraries this kind of makes your
prototype for your prototype production
ready because all the elasticity your
infrastructure
and the computing power is managed by
the cloud provider so in a way you don't
have to worry too much about performance
and about not being production ready of
course you get a restful interface for
free you can version your model very
simply I'll be talking a bit more about
it obvious lambda which is the Amazon
Web Services tool that we used and you
also get caching for free like content
delivery network worldwide so that your
mobile users in Australia will be served
directly from Australia not from you
know Virginia or Oregon the idea is that
you can do offline training so once you
deploy a lambda function the function is
immutable so you cannot update it in you
know you cannot update a code in real
time you need to redeploy it and that
deployment will be immutable again so
all the training phase need to be
performed of now flying fashion
eventually even in in lambda itself but
you have like a five-minute time
limitation so it's not really
recommended if you unless you have a
tiny tiny little model and you can also
achieve a be testing if you have many
different like you cannot choose your
model which model performs better maybe
you have a small data set or maybe three
different models perform pretty well but
you didn't you do not know which one of
them will be actually the best you know
production environment with real users
or with real content so it be testing
for us was a very key point and we
achieved this in a transparent way we'd
have by having like one lambda function
for each model and by putting another
lambda function in front of them that
will decide which lambda which model
will be actually used for the given user
and so at this link you can find a
simple github repository with an example
so we trained a binary classifier a very
simple model for a sentiment analysis
and then we
documented how to take this model built
it with scikit-learn
and how to deploy it to AWS lambda and
connect it to api gateway in order to
have a restful interface so you can
check this this code it's very simple
repo you're just a few files and the
user interface will be something like
this okay so you can say I love Python
predict sentiment this is a simple HTML
page with some few lines of JavaScript
so this is positive and what do we say I
don't know I hate Java sorry okay the
sentiment is negative so if we if you
check what happens under the hood we are
just calling an HTTP endpoint and we
give it a sentence and it will tell us
positive or negative so this is our
machine learning micro service that will
scale automatically now I can call this
endpoint hundred times per second it
will always answer respond in a few
milliseconds this is a scalability okay
this is a very simple example one model
like very small data set and very quick
response okay let's talk about a real
world example so we build this
architecture internally at cloud Academy
we are on AWS and so we wanted to have a
multi model architecture as I mentioned
we ended up with same old more than 50
models and we are using an all the AWS
services as far as storage and database
like s3 and RDS to store both our data
our events in our raw data and our
models as well I will show you in a
second the architecture and as I
mentioned they are flying the training
is performed offline on a periodic
fashion so every few hours I can just
take the new events that arrived into my
database or my data warehouse and I will
retrain my models and upload them
and I'll show you more or less how it
works so I don't know if you're familiar
with AWS style charts I will try to
summarize very briefly on so these are
our applications mobile application and
web application and also our web server
eventually which our users will use
every day and what happens is that all
the infrastructure is inside and in AWS
region and we will be able to so our ups
are able to reach our alumni functions
our machine learning models through a
restful interface which is provided by
API gateway another AWS service that you
can just bind to a lambda function go to
a end of list lambda back end and so we
decided to store our models our
serialized models into s3 which is the
simple storage service provided by AWS
which allows you to basically upload any
kind of object any kind of file to their
to their cloud and what happens under
the hood is that all our data is stored
it is stored in RDS database or our data
arrives all our events that we generate
I will show you what our data collection
pipeline looks like it is 99% server
lists as well so when our data are
collected from our applications we stir
them into an RDS or or redshift database
and we use these spot instances or
eventually any kind of instance even
your local machine if you want to
periodically retrain the model reading
touching you know fetching the data and
a raw data from our days you know you
aggregate you transform you clean and
you finally train your model you see
realize it and you just upload it to s3
what happens is that our lambda
functions will be running in the
meanwhile you know every time I see a
user calls the HTTP endpoint the lambda
function will check if the
three file if there's three object which
means if the model itself has been
updated or not so that you can version
your models and every time you have a
new version you will overwrite the
previous version on s3 but eventually
you can always roll back
so we achieved in the first version that
we develop these lambda and a3
interaction was not needed because we
were practically deploying the model
itself with the lambda function code so
you just take you just comprised your
code in a zip file and you say okay
lambda this is my code really please use
it whenever a user calls the lambda
function so you can upload any kind of
file and if you package your machine
learning model your serialized model
with the lambda function code that will
work as well but then we realize that
many lambda functions will end up using
the same model so after each training
phase in sorry after each training phase
instead of the redeploying all these
lambda function they might be 5 6 10 and
you need to remember which number
function is using which model okay I
said no let's deploy the model let's
upload the models on as three and
without redeploying on the function they
will simply pull the new updated model
from s3 so these schedules automatically
and the operation required to do all of
this are very simple there is no
develops no web developer involved our
data science team can simply you know
either click click a couple of buttons
or run a few scripts on the spot
instance and everything will be updated
with the new data what about our data
collection pipeline so this is more or
less serverless as well meaning that
there are not you know most of the
infrastructure will automatically scale
in a managed way I don't know if you
guys know segment comm it's a quite
interesting service also based on AWS
that you basically it multiplexes your
data into your third parties integration
so you can say okay segment is my event
from the mobile app or from the website
and segment will send these events you
know to Google Analytics to Mixpanel
to you know any other third party
services that you need your data in but
interesting feature is that you can also
point a web book to segment comm so
every book is basically an HTTP endpoint
so you say okay when an event comes to
to this segment please also call this
endpoint and pass all the data as well
so we saw segment is highly available
and the last thing because it's based on
AWS and you know it will be very very
bad if you your in your data ingestion
pipeline within scale as well because
then you will miss events or you will
have problems at some point so we
connected this segment comm web book
with our HTTP endpoint offered by API
gateway which we'll call a lambda
function that will validate the event
check it that it's actually coming from
the cloud Academy mobile or web
application and then we'll store it into
a queue that arcs smaller less like a
buffer because you don't want to
overload your database so if like a
thousand events come in a second you
don't want to you want to have a kind of
a buffer here instead of writing
directly into the database and this also
allows you to better the back your data
or even to switch your data warehouse
off for a couple of hours you will still
have like one week about pair of events
so as soon as you switch your little
routes on again you can just keep
collecting and writing data into the
database so this was to avoid first of
all to lose data and to eventually be
able to do database maintenance and it
allows maintenance and what happens here
in the middle is that with a fleet of
servers or in some instances
or any even your local machine again
could do this you will just read the
event from the queue manipulated you
know adapted to the RTS we use
phosphorus to the RDS schema and just
write it into the database as I met as I
showed before these RDS database will be
used for the periodic offline training
phase so every one hour every six hours
depending on the model we will be able
to fetch new data aggregated train and
redeploy the model and this can be
completely automated we are thinking to
do also the training phase with lambda
itself but you have some limitation you
have limitation as far as how much local
storage you have how long can the
execution be now it's only five minutes
not really great if you have a big model
or if you have to aggregate or store too
much data and another interesting
problem that you have with this approach
I will go through the limitations I mean
it's very powerful because these
infrastructure will automatically scale
if you go from a hundred user to you
know a million user ok overnight very
few companies have this problem but if
you if your service is actually a great
service it might happen so you know you
don't want to think about it and I've
done like one week of downtime because
you are too lazy to build your
infrastructure this is it and so there
are some limitations on you cannot do
real-time models meaning you cannot
update the model with new upcoming
events in real time like you could do
with other solutions so you can have a
pseudo real-time like every half an hour
eventually every 5 minutes you could
return your model unless it takes two
hours to train so this really depends on
your use case then there are some
limitations about the deployment package
that you can build
the toughest problem here was how to
manage operating system libraries okay
if you use scikit-learn or numpy or
sci-fi you have a lot of you know C and
Fortran and you know very efficient
operating system libraries like Atlas
and others that are not available among
them so for the first couple of days I
thought this is not possible there's no
way it is lambda for this but you know
we work all together in the serverless
community to make it work and you can
find a couple of hacks to basically load
the operating system libraries into the
Python interpreter before your lambda
function executes dynamically so you
have to ship and deploy the Fortran C
whatever libraries as well with your own
code and okay you can make this easier
with some automation tools that if
you're curious I can link them later now
actually you can find them in the
repository the sentiment analysis
example as I mentioned you cannot do
model training within a WS lambda itself
because of the five minutes execution
but if you have a tiny little model well
why not you can also schedule the
execution up lambda function every one
hour or every five minutes every 12
hours so instead of managing a machine
and setting cron jobs you can also use
lambda for the periodic training phase
here there's another big problem called
cold start
so what lambda does at the end of the
day is you know spawning a lot of
containers and shipping your code into
these containers so in order to scale up
as soon as there are too many requests
to handle they will redeploy many
different containers with your code
inside this spawning time you know this
spawning operation can take a few you
know some time and so the first time you
call your run the function maybe you
noticed when I forced
I love Python in the analysis in the
sentimentalized example so it might take
even one second two seconds to startup
the container and so you don't have this
problem if you constantly call your
lambda function and if you have enough
traffic to keep it warm all the time so
some people are even manually calling
the function just to keep it warm every
few minutes that's not a big deal but
let's say if you are using scikit-learn
or other you know scientific libraries
like Syfy and M PI this constant time is
even longer you know it's just importing
Saipa it can take like a couple of
seconds itself just name import sci fi
operation because a lot of stuff is
going on and so this one second
cold start time will become three
seconds easily so you want to keep you a
function warm as much as possible mmm
also we had a few problems with you know
unit integration tests because now our
data scientists can deploy microservices
into production without the help of any
one of no one so you can just you know
you need some tool you still need to
help them you know write unit tests
before deploying the fun on the function
you want to test it locally you want to
test that the interface the restful
interface didn't change that it still
accepts all the parameters that the
clients will will pass so they this has
really helped but there is no native
mechanism to do this within end of this
lambda so you either write your own
tools or you use what the community is
giving you for example you could use the
service framework which is a great
resource and now supports not only AWS
but also assure functions and other
Google is coming soon and IBM open wisk
is coming soon as well exactly so the
ecosystem is growing not only cloud
platform like AWS or Microsoft Google
IBM but also you know specific function
as a service tools like iron dot IO or
whoo
allows you to just bring your own code
and deploy it as a function also in
order to make your application you know
faster to develop you could use others
like several services like firebase or
of zero that will solve some problems
like how do you integrate a database how
do you integrate authentication into
into your micro services so if you are
just applying machine learning models is
not a big deal it's like a very isolated
micro service you don't need to write
too much stuff in your database or into
you know authentication services and
that's all thank you very much for
coming of course we use Python a lot and
you're welcome we are hiring we have a
net quarter in San Francisco and one in
Europe in Switzerland so I'm from Italy
please let me know if you're interested
thank you again if you have any
questions I think we have some time
doing yeah sorry I forgot to mention
that so at this level on API gateway you
have many different options okay please
I think the power of API gateway is that
you can choose based on the client you
could use I am you could use
authentication keys you could use either
lambda function that will act as
customer authorizers so in depending on
the case we use all of these three so in
some simple cases and an API key is
enough in some other cases you want to
have like from the browser you want to
have we use a custom authorizer
written in lambda that will check your
API key into our own single sign-on
service and it will decide if you are
authorized or not
yeah that that berry depends on who is
calling so if it's a server-to-server
call an API key could be enough it
really depends if you are calling you're
in our case we are the most the biggest
users of our machine learning models so
it will be our web server or our web or
mobile application so we don't need user
uses plans because we are the only users
of our own models so an API key from the
server or from the mobile app could be
enough but from the browser for example
you want to use like user you know on a
per user per user solution so the user
will give you his own credentials and
you will validate that into your custom
SSO or whatever you are using and the
other question logging
you know it's very interesting because
you can have logging both at the API
gateway level and at the lambda level so
you will have automatically you don't
even have to say I want them it's
automatic it's perfect it's not free but
it's like super cheap with WN Amazon
Cloud watch is the logging service of
AWS so every lambda function invocation
and every print you make inside your
lambda function will be logged as well
into cloud watch and the same if you
enable it for every API get a call yes
you mean how did we integrate the oh
yeah so if you check the the github
repository that I linked there is a
lambda function folder and so you can
see there is a model that you can deploy
with your lung function there is the
actual code and there is the mod module
in it and here you can see the hack
where the hack is read every file from
the lib folder and if it's not a dot a
file you will have only a dot all as
files and load it into the interpreter
and dynamically so before executing a
lambda function before instantiating all
the code you will load into the
interpreter or your operating system
libraries this is the trick and if you
check the readme of the repo you can
find a very useful article by Ryan Brown
that explained just this how to use
scikit-learn within it obvious lambda
another question one more question
well if you're cold changes you have to
redeploy there is no I mean deploying
your I would not recommend it for
security reasons and because you also
want to track your lambda function
versions because you can always roll
back to a previous version if it doesn't
work so if you do this and redeploy the
code and create a new version you have
the rollback feature by default if you
don't do it you can never go back if you
just pull the code it's very unsafe I
think and you cannot roll back another
question and we decided to use the
service framework which does most of
this for you so you can test your lambda
function locally with a custom define
event locally and it's very simple you
just say Travis framework test my other
function this event you can check it
serverless calm and this is a new
open-source project not very new like
already one year old from San Francisco
check check it out it's very very useful
yeah it was only AWS but now it also
works with other cloud providers so it's
growing very quickly it's like twelve
thousand stars on github it's pretty
pretty nice rifle give it a try another
oh good thank you everyone for coming
again